- So you've talked about
your son coming out.
So what lessons have your kids taught you?
- Honestly KELLY, they teach
me more lessons I think,
than I teach them they teach
me a lot about language.
I was really had a hard time
wrapping my brain around
the gender pronouns because
to me, they is plural.
And so I'm you know, I'm a
Dinosaur, in a way of that.
So ,they teach me and I think,
you know they're not always patient.
So that can suck at times but
- Yeah
- I made things for me that I have to try.
They teach me the issues they're
so much more aware of
because they're living them.
My son came out in 7th grade,
you know, he was I just thought it was
the bravest thing ever,
and you really see other
people's reactions to it.
You kind of end up knowing who
people are, how they think.
And then they'll feed me the facts
and tell me what's up with the protests.
I always like to think I know
things but they know more.
So my job a lot right now is to listen,
and learn, listen and learn.
- Yeah, I think that's a lot of
our job is educating ourselves.
And it is funny again, as a mom, I like
it's what I even have with kids ranging
from 4 to 19 in our household,
but it's like, you find out I mean yes,
you're helping helping mood this life,
but you also are, you're changing
like it changes you in the best way.
And it really does make you
like, self examination becomes
so prominent, and like what you say
and like, you get called out like
your kids are like Wait, what?
And then you hear them say,
and you're like oh, maybe
I shouldn't do that.
Like, it's that's really does change you
and it's it when I think it changes you
when you're a present
great parent, I think so.
It must be amazing
- Yeah and you know,
we argue I'm not gonna
to say we don't we argue
and I want to understand.
- Oh So do we.
- Yeah, and it's it's part of it.
I think that first of all you
know, we're in drama right?
So you feel like there's no real world
without drama without conflict,
and there's no accomplishment
without conflict.
So I get it but you know, but there's
a everything is in such flux right now.
And the world is changing
hopefully for the better,
but it's breaking out just so much hatred
and so much anger and
you don't wanna give up
on systems that you
knew and felt safe with.
But then now you see them in a new light,
you go Oh, I guess we need a new system.
And then it's the forming of that system
that I'm probably more Old
world I wanna you know,
be careful as we form it
and they're like, excuse my
- caution to the wind, Yeah.
- Great nevermind no caution
to the wind, Let's change now.